[Music]
cory's kicking off this hour in
fayetteville arkansas cory welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you good afternoon hey how you
doing how can we help
you doing well thank you hey got a
question uh me and my wife are currently
on baby step six uh we're a family of
six
and living in about a twenty four
hundred square foot home if everything
comes to fruition the way we planned it
or the house paid off in about four to
five years awesome um
when we initially bought the home eight
years ago it was just five of us that
it just fine
yeah yeah that additional child kind of
threw us for a loop in many ways and uh
we're kind of running out of space and
so just wanting to
look at
we've looked at remodeling adding on
it's just with our current layout it'll
make it very difficult not really
wanting to sell we really love the
neighborhood the
uh the land we have etc but we're also
struggling real bad with space it's just
kind of wanting to pick you your guy's
brain if you could
yeah so have you looked at the market
right now and where you would go and how
much that would cost
yeah i mean
like everywhere else we're very
fortunate with increased property value
so our homes uh worth more but of course
other homes are also selling for more as
well so i think if we were to buy what
you would set us off of our plan by
uh you know maybe additional five to
seven years and so uh not really wanting
to do that but also
like i said really hurting for space
right now
yeah i mean that's a that's a lot corey
i just have three little ones and i feel
like we're just for each other i have
just zero and i'm like it sounds like a
lot i've got a little dawn i mean yeah
corey i mean you guys are y'all are in
the baby steps
spots that baby step four through six
where we say like hey
you don't have to be gazelle intense you
want to have a goal and pay it off but
you also can let your foot off the gas
and kind of
enjoy life a little bit so you guys
we're gonna be able to pay it off in
three to five years now it'll be five to
seven years and for just the sanity and
the state of mind and the the lifestyle
value that more room can just bring
i think that's not a bad move i think
for you guys i mean as long as you
again have that that house payment's not
crazy and you get a good you have a good
down payment
all of that you could still
knock it out maybe even sooner than five
to six five to seven years but um but
that quality of life you're at the part
of the baby steps where you're able to
make those decisions and that it's not
that's not a wrong decision
yeah and as long as it's within the
parameters that you know i recommend
rachel recommends where the payment is
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay on a 50 15-year fixed rate mortgage
and i assume you'd have a big old down
payment selling this one and going into
the next one right
yeah we're i mean
currently we have anywhere from
250 000 to 315 000 in equity that's
great towards the next home yeah yeah so
i mean you're not doing a bad thing it
sounds like you were just pumped on
paying off this house and now it's like
man it's setting us back but if you kind
of zoom out you are doing so much better
than the average american that you guys
should be celebrating going all right
we're gonna pay our house off in five
years and we have taken care of this
family of six
so well and we're creating the space
that we need so that none of us go crazy
uh i think that's a great thing
and uh
you know five years instead of three in
the grand scheme of your life you're
gonna have a paid for house that's even
bigger that's gonna cost more um to
celebrate so i'm pumped for you guys i
think that's the right move obviously
the market's crazy right now so as much
patience as you want to buy as you kind
of figure out you know i don't want you
rushing into this or being forced into
it where you go well we gotta put 50
over because the market's crazy make
sure you're working with a really good
real estate agent who can help you land
a deal that's right for you guys
yeah i appreciate that i guess one more
thing conversely too is in order homes
are going so fast about time they go in
the market you have practically four
hours to make a decision which is crazy
to me to think about a uh you know 500
000 plus home to have only four hours to
make a decision or you'll lose it yeah
no it's it's stressful it is that's why
you need to know exactly what you want
when you put a payment on or i'm sorry
an offer in to be able to say okay yep
we feel comfortable when we put this off
around we feel comfortable if they take
this offer the things around it and the
terms to the agreement we feel good
about and yeah it is i mean it's it's
just it's a fast-moving market and if
you're not financially in a good spot
that's when you can make some really bad
decisions but if you guys financially
have a plan you have your money you you
know what you're looking for you guys
are on a team together you and your wife
you can you you can make a quick
decision but it it feels rushed which
i'm totally honest don't go waving
inspections and appraisals and all these
things those super important things that
you don't want to skip thanks for the
call